日本の歯医者
第四章
僕がスカイスリーパーに座った瞬間、お姉さんが一人部屋に入ってきて、
「今から歯を磨きますがよろしいですか」と聞いてくる。
「大丈夫です」と僕が答えると、お姉さんは、
「その前に下半身の緊張をほぐす必要がありますので」
と言いながらトランスフォーマーからローションを取り出してたっぷり手に付け、
そして僕のベルトへと手を伸ばし――
すみません、今のは聞かなかったことにしてください。
「口をあけて頂けますか？」
僕がYUKIちゃんとマチュピチュの緑の段々畑を一緒に登っていると、
マスクをした男性が診察室に入ってきて、隣に椅子を引き寄せて座り、そう言った。
「あ、虫歯があるみたいですね」
「この奥歯は磨きにくいんですよねぇ……」
歯医者の言葉に頷くともなく頷いていると
またBRAVIAに吸い込まれる。
段々畑の上の方から褐色の肌をしたペルー人女性が降りてきて、
「遅れてすみません。マリアです」と挨拶すると、マチュピチュについて色々と説明をしてくれた。
話しながら、彼女は風が吹く度に
中指で長い茶色い髪を耳の後ろにかき上げた。
YUKIちゃんは僕の脇をツンツンして、
「なんかシャンプーのCMっぽくない？」
と小声で言って笑った。
「じゃあ今から詰めますね。痛かったら――」
マリアは、
「それでは今から山頂に向かいますが、その前にマチュピチュについてのご質問などはありますか？」　と言う。
YUKIは、
「インカ人は車輪を使わずにマチュピチュを作ったと聞いたことありますが、本当ですか？」 と聞く。
マリアは得意げに微笑み、「そうです」と答えた。
「はい終わりました」
「車輪を使わずにこんな山の上に街を作るなんて……」
「本当にすごいですね、道元さん……」
「道元さん…」
「道元さん、聞いてますか？」
「はい？」
マリアの唇から歯医者の顔に視線を移す僕。
「もう終わりましたよ、道元さん」
「え？」
歯医者は慣れた手つきでマスクを外し、
「道元さんはずいぶん我慢強いですね」
「これからは奥歯にも気を付けてくださいね」
と笑って言った。
後ろに立っていたお姉さんは
僕を見てウインクをした。
ミニカの、背もたれを倒したままの、
というより普通に壊れた運転席に横になると、
壁から漏れてくる電動ドリルの音や人の泣き声を２０分ほど聞かされる。
これも拷問の一つなんだろうか。
やがてドアの開く音がし、
二、三秒して閉まる音がする。
が、そのあとは何も音がしない。
気になって体を起こして部屋を見回すと………
……誰もいないじゃないか。
ぞっとしつつ、
周りを気にしながら、
再びミニカ椅子に横たわる。
もう２０分ノイズ拷問に耐えると
またドアが開き、
今度は禿げ上がったホビットが部屋に入ってくる。
小型の双眼鏡がついたメガネみたいなものを掛けていて、
全身からいかにもホビットらしいキツい体臭を漂わせている。
彼は僕の隣までやってきていきなり声を上げた。
「で？」
「虫歯…ですが」
「虫歯…………」
「虫歯…………ねぇ！」
ホビットは拷問道具のところに行って、自分の小さくて毛深い手でそれらを撫で始めた。
「なぜ虫歯が出来るか、」
「分かるかね？」
「……砂糖や、食べ物――」
ホビットは僕の答えには興味がなかった。
「怠惰だよ」
僕は胃がビクッとするのが分かった。
これがいわゆる「歯医者の取り調べ」なのだ。
「道元は、釣りは好きかね？」
そう言いながら、ホビットは怪しく微笑み、釣り針のついたボールペンを持ち上げてみせた。
「釣りは好きかって聞いてるんだが？」
とその時、壁から漏れてくる悲鳴。
「………好きです」
僕は震えながら答えた。
ホビットはちらりと僕を見て、笑った。
「ならいい」
彼は釣り針をテーブルに戻し、
今度は何か紫色の液体の入った注射器を持ち上げてみせた。
「もう一つ、質問してもいいかね？」
その質問にすでに怯えながらも、
小刻みに頷く僕。
「道元さんは怠け者かね？」
「怠け者って言われれば……」
「たまには歯磨きを忘れ――」
僕が話し終わらないうちに
ホビットはいきなり注射針を僕の歯茎に突き立てた。
強烈な痛みに全身がこわばり、
目に涙が浮かんだ。
「さてと…」
「詰めるか」
そう言うとホビットは拷問道具のテーブルの下から削岩機としか表しようのないものを取り出して、
僕の椅子に脚を掛けると僕の上にまたがり、
そして錆びついた道具の先を僕の唇に当てた。
「『あぁ』ってするんだ」
僕は目をつぶってミニカの安っぽい肘掛けを握りしめた。
「頑張れ、忍耐は美徳だ」